and winning his game today sam savion
he's had a good tournament but he
finally feels like he broke through sam
how do you feel today
it definitely feels good to finally win
a game
i've had a few chances tournament but i
really didn't
convert well let's look at your game sam
because that was simply a masterpiece uh
when did you feel you're taking over
uh it was actually near the end of the
game when i played queen h5
i have a very powerful opponent not
before
no not before we can go through the game
yeah let's let's let's go through the
game um
where do you want to start because uh
this is knight g4 queen f6 idea yeah
sure we can go down there yeah it felt
like you came in
looking for blood right i mean
ga g5 you threw the kitchen sink at him
and i was really happy about this knight
d8 move because
yeah the knight's just going to f4 and
either you have to give away your
italian bishop or allow it to land on f4
right and it feels that
i i did feel it was a bit impractical to
um
to allow it to allow knight but the
engine was suggesting that after night
for knight d5 was a very strong move in
this position i'm actually interested in
that line so knight d5 knight takes e2
you take back a queen d8 and they just
wanted to kick out this guy on g4 with
h3
i think the move knight h6 fails
tactically right yeah probably just
bishop g5 i was i think i wanted to play
c6 c6 is probably forced and i think the
surprising part was how it evaluated
this as so much better for
for what that's definitely surprising so
bishop takes g4
c4
g4 and it is a computer so you can
imagine oh it just takes the box it just
collects it thinks
pawns are free thank you very much
and it did give white a sizeable
advantage but of course a very scary
line seeing it from afar also down the
exchange
uh but after rook d2 it almost felt like
it was his final mistake did he play
rook d too fast uh relatively yeah
relatively quickly
yeah perhaps i didn't feel the danger of
this position i'm definitely happy about
knight takes e3 and g4
uh he found an interest was a huge
detail we have very important detail
with knight h3
oh yes that issue is important because
if let's say queen g5 ef africa f2 yeah
but put that
and you no longer have that pawn on e5
to
attack the center bishop on a7 is going
to stay locked forever
right
so we got to this position and it felt
you got everything you wanted
i think his the the reason i said quench
5 is because when i played rook df-8
here
one of the key
ideas in this position is that if you
take on f8 and play rook f2 yeah uh i
can take on f2 and he cannot recapture
with the queen because if adcd bishop
takes d4 so
that pin actually works for me
um
and what he did is he can you go queen
f7 after taking on d4 yeah f7 here it's
on a little bit of counter play
oh yes that's a good move
king d8 though can you then now take on
d4 you can do it before after doesn't
really matter
you can you can still take yeah king d8
is a big move
kinky seven i still seem safe yet yeah
you're still good yeah you can even go
to c6 probably yes
the engine defends it but we don't care
what the engine thinks
so so i think his big mistake is b5 uh
because he allowed me to play a5 and
then bishop b6 the king goes to a7 under
post right uh if he played a5 instead of
b5 i would have to play c6
and my king is still weak right in that
position yeah but now he's extremely
happy right just has no moves
maybe this is the time that he should
have gone for takes takes in rook after
oh yeah for sure for sure yeah and
without the ability of going to c6 in
many variations but he missed that
chance and it felt once this king got to
a seven i love it by the way very cast
power of like right you improve your
king to the maximum before you get that
killing blow and
this it was a very bad symptom this
bishop c1 bishop d2
and once you put the queen on h5 we saw
how you put this queen on g4 you
certainly must have fouled you were
winning yeah yeah here i felt like it's
close to winning
yeah h4 coming
with great effect sam tell us a little
bit about uh your year in chess not so
much in the calendar their year but
you've had not so busy but very
successful year uh in the past few
tournaments you've uh attained all-time
highs in your rating uh what's what's
clicked
uh well i played no tournaments during
the pandemic as many people
also weren't able to play
and i basically just worked on chess
those two years
i've only played four or five events i'd
say
that's the pandemic but but they went
well they went very well
well that work is definitely paying off
sam congratulations once again and good
luck in the rest of your games thank you
absolutely sam savian one of the
strongest players here in america